today
私はスポーツを通じて豊かな世の中を作るため日々活動しています
時には世界最高峰の障害物レースに出たりもします
しかし私は子どもの頃
運動音痴で台の運動嫌いでした
ウソでしょと思われる方もいるかもしれませんが本当なんです
両省の頃初めてのボール投げでボールをキャッチできず
顔面で受け思いっきり鼻血を流しました
けれどその私が今財団の代表を務め子どもたちと一緒に思いっきり体を動かし
スポーツは豊かな世の中を作ることができると信じて活動しているのですから自分でも
驚きです
何故これほどまでスポーツの力を信じられるようになったのか
そこには私が大切にしている
人は
変化に対応し進化することで成長するという考え方があるのです
私は福島県いわき市の商店街にあった
紳士服店の2階で生まれました
1階の店舗では父が仕入れをし
はぁが販売をし私は23才の頃まで店頭にあるは後に紐で繋がれ
客様にやっしゃいませ
ありがとうございましたといわば看板犬ならぬ
看板娘でした
父が立ち上げた小さな紳士服店は次々と出店し拡大していきました
そしてその後
二転三転
4.5点と当時はカメレオンカンパニーと言われるほど
筐体を変化させていきました
ですから氏が会社でいうことは日々変わりました
昨日言ったことは強化割強言ったことも明日には変わるという感じです
なぜそうコロコロ言うことが変わるのかと質問すると
父は
世の中は常に変化する
その変化に対応し進化したものこそ生き残る
そう話してくれました
私はというと
小さい時から天候や引っ越しでこんにちはさようなら
の日々
そんな生活に慣れるうち中学校の終わりの頃には自ら福島を飛び出し
仙台
東京サンディエゴボストン
あるセラーんと28歳の頃まで飛び回っていました
しかし私が最も尊敬し信頼する父は
ある日突然旅行先でなくなりました
今から15年前2003年のことです
経営のことはもちろん人としての生き方を教えてくれた父でしたので
私の心にはほっかり大きな穴が開き
まったく現実味がありませんでした
父が
教えてくれたことは
人は
変化に対応し進化することで成長するということをずっと教えてくれてましたので私が
生まれた時からその考えは私のそばにあったのです
そして
私の人生でもう一つ大きな変化を与えたことが2011年3月11日
東日本大震災です
市の実家は福島県安芸市
はぁの実家は宮城県石巻市て私は多くの親戚友人知人を失いました
シャラ日は
経営していたスポーツ店70店舗が倒壊し破損しました
実はあのときの記憶は今でも断片的です
確実に覚えているのは心から生きていたいと思ったこと
生きているということは奇跡でありそうして生かされた私に何ができるのかということ
を考え始めました
倒壊したテンポで最初に始めたのは70店舗から
テントキャンプ用品を取り出し
そして地域の人々が集まれる場所を作りました
しかしそこの場所にいた子どもたちからはすっかり笑顔は消えていました
親兄弟親戚
そして家までも失った子どもたちですから笑顔が出るはずもありませんよね
そんな中支援の輪が広がり
世界中から多くのアスリートも支援に来てくれました
ある日私は nba のレジェンドプレイヤーとともに
宮城県塩竈市立の中学校に行くことがありました
何人かの子どもたちはその日までボールを触ることさえ拒んでいました
レジェンドに背中を押されボールでパスを始めたとき
洒落まで無表情だった子どもたちに
笑顔は戻り涙を流し始めたんです
今でも鮮明に覚えています
これほど苦しい状況にあっても
スポーツには人を笑顔にする力がある
生きる力を与えてくれる力がある
そう強く感じたのです
それまでの私はスポーツはスポーツが好きな人
スポーツができる人だけのものだと思っていました
しかし
無表情だった子どもたちの変化を見たと思う
スポーツの持つ力を実感したのです
そして
その子供たちを見たときスポーツが生活の中にあることで
人生がより感動的で楽しくなる
そしてそういう人がたくさん増えることで
より豊かな湯の中が作られるのではないか
それは衝撃的な発見でした
今ここにいる子供たちのためにできることをやっていこうというエネルギーが沸いてき
たのです
この事が
財団設立のきっかけとなりました
私たちの最初の活動は放射能問題で外に出られない子どもたちのための無料の運動施設
の解説でした
実は震災後
福島の子どもたちの肥満率は一気に増加しました
子どもたちが外で遊ぶ体を動かすという当たり前のことがこれほど重要なことか
私は改めて実感することになります
そして財団は活動の場を広げ様々なスポーツイベントを企画し今では60万人以上の
子どもたちにスポーツの機会を提供しています
中でも持っても力を入れているのが小学生を対象とした
スポーツキャンプです
2003日子供達だけで過ごし
様々な競技の元日本代表選手
フラー3とに直接指導を行ってもらい
夜は英語での交流会を行うなど子どもたちはさまざまな体験をします
このキャンプでは時々やほぼ毎回
事件をおります
初日は緊張する子どもたちを深めになるとリラックスしたかと思うとケンカ勃発
あげくの果てにうまくいかないことに腹を歌って大暴れしたかと思うと平裾
2キャンプに参加しているボランティア我々スタッフはある意味しにものぐるいです
それでもある子はキャンプを振り返って自分にできる競技は一つだけでなくたくさん
あることを知った
またある子はキャンプに参加して初めての人とも積極的に話ができるようになった
お話してくれました
2003日というわずかな時間ですが
スポーツキャンプが子どもたちの成長に大きな影響を与えていることを私はとても
うれしく感じています
そして今では確信しています
私が大切にしている人は変化に対応し進化することで成長するということにスポーツが
大きな力を与えているということ
私は先日ブエノスアイレスで開催された第一回
オリンピズムアクション in フォーラムに参加してきました
そこには答えリク
150カ国1500人以上の人が集まり
スポーツの力で平和な社会をつくるためさまざまなトピックでディスカッションが行わ
れました
スポーツが国際社会を継続的により良い方向に発展させるため
2020年に開催される東京オリンピックパラリンピック以降も日本が担う役割は
とても大きなものがあると思っています
チャレンジすることを怖がらず
様々なことをして進化し
仲間と影響し合って成長する
子どもたちがスポーツを通じてそういった体験をできる場をこれからも作っていきたい
と思っています
私は幼少の頃から変化の人生を過ごしてきました
そしてしの指令
授業決議
東日本大震災で多くをしない
絶望の淵に立たされました
それでも今この日を迎えています
それはその時々の変化を受け入れ自分自身に力をつけ
進化し成長してきたからに他ならないと思うのです
今日この会場にお越しの皆さんも日々変化し進化し成長して今を迎えていることと思い
ます
時には辛く苦しい出来事に立ち止まってしまい
前に踏み出せない日もあるでしょう
軽度進化したことでできなかったことが出来るようになる喜びは何事にも代えがたいと
私は思うのです
そうすることで自分なりの幸せな人生を送ることができると私は身をもって感じてい
ます
変化
進化
成長
皆さんも是非
今よりも一歩
前に踏み出してみてください
ありがとうございました
[拍手]